round seven of the London chess classic  the last stop on the grand chest tour  with just three rounds to go the best  chess players on the planet came into  the day focused and determined to score  a much-needed victory jana Pagliacci  played a sharp game against former world  champion Vishwanath on Anand and when  the smoke had cleared the Russian star  won in dominating style and left into a  tie for first in the tournament that  left other players desperately needing  to win to give chase which Maxime vasila  grabbed did in a powerful end game  against Sergei Kuryakin and magnus  carlsen did though he had to pull a  rabbit out of a hat against hometown  favorite michael adams at least  practically speaking I didn't think of  possibly hold us they are rounding the  bend with the finish line in sight the  exciting penultimate round of the season  and classic starts right now